>>> WE ARE JUST GETTING STUNNING
NEW DETAILS ABOUT FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HIS LAWYER'S
EFFORT TO DELAY THE
CERTIFICATION OF THE 2020
ELECTION.
AN EMAIL TURNED OVER TO THE
JANUARY 6th SELECT COMMITTEE
INDICATES ONE OF TRUMP'S LAWYERS
THOUGHT SUPREME COURT JUSTICE
CLARENCE THOMAS WOULD BE KEY TO
THEIR PLANS.
CNN'S KAITLIN POLLANCE HELPED TO
BREAK THIS STORY.
>> Reporter: EMAILS WHERE DONALD
TRUMP'S LAWYERS WERE DISCUSSING
WHAT TO DO WHENEVER THEY WERE
FILING CASES AFTER THE ELECTION
TO OVERTURN THE RESULT OF THAT
ELECTION AND THESE EMAILS WE ARE
NOW SEEING THEM IN WRITING, THIS
IS EXACTLY WHAT WAS SAID THAT
CONVINCED A FEDERAL JUDGE THAT
THEY MAY HAVE BEEN ENGAGED IN
PLANNING A CRIME, SPECIFICALLY
DEFRAUDING THE UNITED STATES
AFTER THAT ELECTION.
I WANT TO READ SOME OF THEM.
WE KNEW ABOUT THEM BEFORE THAT
FEDERAL JUDGE DAVID O. CARTER
DESCRIBED THEM IN COURT BUT NOW
WE'RE SEEING THEM BECAUSE THEY
WERE PROVIDED IN A LINK IN A
COURT FILING LAST NIGHT VERY
EARLY IN THE MORNING.
SO ONE OF THEM IS FROM ATTORNEY
KEN CHEESE, TO CHALLENGE THE
ELECTION.
HE WROTE TO OTHER ATTORNEYS ON
DECEMBER 31st, 2020, IF WE CAN
JUST GET THIS CASE PENDING
BEFORE THE SUPREME COURT BY
JANUARY 5th, IDEALLY WITH
SOMETHING POSITIVE WRITTEN BY A
JUDGE OR JUSTICE HOPEFULLY
THOMAS, I THINK IT'S OUR BEST
SHOT AT HOLDING UP THE COUNT OF
A STATE IN CONGRESS.
SO THERE'S CHESEBRO SAYING THEY
WANT TO GET IT BEFORE A
FAVORABLE JUDGE AND CHALLENGE IT
IN COURT NOT BECAUSE THEY WANTED
TO LITIGATE IT BUT WANTED A
REASON FOR CONGRESS NOT TO
ASSERT JOE BIDEN AS THE
PRESIDENT AND INSTEAD KEEP THE
POSSIBILITY ALIVE THAT DONALD
TRUMP COULD CONTINUE CHALLENGING
THE ELECTION.
CHESEBRO WROTE IN ANOTHER EMAIL
ON DECEMBER 31st NEW YEAR'S EVE
2020, POSSIBLY THOMAS WOULD END
UP BEING THE KEY HERE, CIRCUIT
JUSTICE, RIGHT?
WE WANT TO FRAME THINGS SO THAT
THOMAS COULD BE THE ONE TO ISSUE
SOME SORT OF STAY OR OTHER
CIRCUIT JUSTICE OPINION SAYING
GEORGIA IS IN LEGITIMATE DOUBT,
SO THIS WAS A LEGAL CHALLENGE
THAT THEY WERE BRINGING IN
GEORGIA IN FEDERAL COURT THAT
DONALD TRUMP WAS ATTESTING TO
THE TRUTH OF FACTS IN A CASE AND
JUSTICE THOMAS WOULD HAVE BEEN
THE PERSON TO RECEIVE THAT
CHALLENGE, OF COURSE, HE ALSO
HAS BEEN UNDER A POLITICAL FUROR
BECAUSE OF SOME OF HIS WIFE'S
COMMENTS ABOUT WANTING TO
CHALLENGE THE ELECTION AS WELL.
BACK TO YOU.
>> AND, OF COURSE, JUST A
REMINDER THAT IT WAS EVENTUALLY
THE SUPREME COURT AS A WHOLE
ENTITY REJECTED ANY OF THESE
CASES RELATED TO ELECTION FRAUD
LAWSUITS THAT THE TRUMP TEAM AND
HIS ALLIES BROUGHT AND THAT WAS
EVEN AFTER THE INSURRECTION SO
THEY DIDN'T EVEN TAKE UP THE
CASE.
KATELYN, THANK YOU.
NORM EISEN IS JOINING US.
WHAT'S SO STUNNING IS THE WHY.
WHY WOULD THEY THINK THAT
CLARENCE THOMAS WOULD SUPPORT
THEM?
IF YOU'RE ON THE JANUARY 6th
COMMITTEE ARE YOU DIGGING DEEP
NEAR THAT NOW?
>> ANA, DEFINITELY.
WE KNOW THAT CLARENCE THOMAS HAD
A COMPLETELY ALTERNATIVE VIEW OF
THE LAW AND THE UNIVERSE.
HE SAID IT WAS BEFUDDLING AND
INEX-FLICKABLE THAT THE SUPREME
COURT DID NOT INTERVENE TO
INVESTIGATE THESE BOGUS AND
FACTUALLY UNFOUNDED CLAIMS, SO
THEY SAW CORRECTLY THAT HE WAS
AN ALLY AND THEN, OF COURSE,
THERE ARE ARE THE QUESTIONS
ABOUT HIS CONFLICTS INVOLVING
HIS WIFE GINNI THOMAS.
>> RIGHT, AND ALL THE TEXT
MESSAGES SHE EXCHANGED WITH
PEOPLE PART OF THE EFFORT TO TRY
TO STOP THE LEGAL TRANSFER OF
POWER AND CERTIFICATION.
NORM, JUSTICES ARE SUPPOSED TO
RECUSE EVEN IF THERE IS AN
APPEARANCE OF CONFLICT OF
INTEREST.
DOES THIS FIT THE BILL HERE?
>> IN ANY OTHER COURT IN THE
COUNTRY UCHDZ FEDERAL LAW, A
JUDGE WHO HAD A SPOUSE WHO HAD
BEEN ADVOCATING A POSITION IN
THIS COMPLETELY ILLEGITIMATE
ATTACK ON THE ELECTION WHICH HAS
BEEN CHARACTERIZED BY ANOTHER
COURT, FEDERAL COURT IN
CALIFORNIA AS AN ATTEMPTED COUP
THAT IS LIKELY CRIMINAL, ANY
OTHER JUDGE WOULD HAVE TO
RECUSE.
IN THE SUPREME COURT YOU KNOW
WHO MAKES THAT DECISION?
CLARENCE THOMAS.
THAT DOESN'T MAKE SENSE IN A
DEMOCRACY.
AS SOMEBODY WHO'S TRAED ETHICS
FOR MORE THAN THREE DECADES AND
ADVISED PRESIDENT OBAMA AND
OTHER PUBLIC OFFICIALS ON THIS,
HE SHOULD NOT HAVE HEARD THAT
CASE AND HE SHOULD NOT BE
HEARING ANYTHING RELATING